hi in the French Alps a slackline spans
18 meters across a deep ravine
Kenny belay begins to make his way
across on a mountain bike suspended over
a 112 metre drop
he's the first ever to manage such a
feat a huge achievement it was like
hadn't done falling off my shoulders I
was there and I liked it was like like
winning four World Championships in in
30 seconds it was it was the best
feeling of my life so far the Belgian
cyclist spent a year training for the
stunt he fell from the slackline often
Heights even if you were attached
falling off
he's always scary it's really not
natural I remember when I fell off the
first time I was screaming like a little
girl
Jenny belay is one of the best mountain
bikers in the world he was just 9 years
old when he entered his first
competition he went on to win one title
after another he spent several weeks
every year training in the Costa Blanca
the Sun is always shining the air is
fresh there's no pollution here for an
athlete this is the best place to be and
to prepare myself for my for my
competitions that's why I come here in
Spain it's a playground to do all
outdoor sports and I this is this is my
life
the sea and the mountains are all within
easy reach here between training
sessions he often chooses a different
sport to relax like the stand-up
paddleboarding in his lunch break
but then it's back to the bike mountain
bike trials are his greatest passion in
this discipline it's all about balance
the rider has to pass through an
obstacle course usually involving rocks
if the riders touch the ground with
their foot they get penalty points
Kenny belay is one the trials world
championship four times and has topped
the international rankings for over 15
years
Street trials are a popular variation of
this discipline for the streets of a
city become the obstacle course
Street trials is more about creativity
and using the natural urban obstacles as
a playground and just be as creative as
possible and play around jump on
everything you see and then spice it up
with some freestyle tricks and I also
like doing that a lot
history trials are perfect for creating
videos that get hundreds of thousands of
clicks online this allows athletes to
market themselves here to Kenny valet
was ahead of the pack
becoming the first trial cyclist to turn
professional in 2003 he's developed his
own show and gone on tour with it
visiting more than 25 countries he loves
to choose the most unlikely places for
his trials like the TV tower in the
Japanese city of Nagoya spectacular
images like these are great for
attracting sponsors in extreme sports
doesn't you it's a it's almost a hype to
always do things that are crazy and more
spectacular and etc etc but the thing is
people always had these dreams I mean
flying an airplane was impossible and of
course you want to promote your sponsors
in a cool way as well but in the first
place you do it for yourself and just
too even if nobody is watching I think
we would still do it and push our limits
and see what is possible relay is
constantly on the lookout for new
obstacles to test his skills right now
it seems like the sky is the limit
only when the Sun drops back behind the
Spanish Mountains does Kenny brulee
finally dropped back a gear ready to
chill for the evening tomorrow is
another day and another challenge